GOOD AFTER AFTERNOON LIGHT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN OUR HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON.
NOTICING THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
ALASKA MADAM SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HERE? MADE TIME.
AGUILAR CURRY HERE.
I THOUGHT.
KOREA PRESENT. BURKE.
FLORA.
LAMONT HERE MCCARTY.
MS AREA. RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
THURMOND WALDRON.
GREAT WILL FIRST BUT BEFORE WE
START I WOULD LIKE TO.
WELCOME TO NEW MEMBERS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SISSY AGAR CURRY WHEN HE JOINED
US AND. A NEWLY ELECTED WHEN DE
CORREO HER VERY HAPPY TO HAVE
YOU BOTH HERE SO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR BEING HERE. AND YOU GET THE
ON TIME AWARD FOR REALLY PRETTY
TOUGH TO GET.
GOOD ROLE MODELS FOR THE REST
THE COMMITTEE.
SO APPRECIATE THAT.
AT THIS POINT WILL LET GO AHEAD
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR AGENDA.
WE WILL HEAR TWO WITNESSES PER
SIDE FOR A TIME LIMIT OF THREE
MINUTES EACH.
AND ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
CAN STATE THEIR NAME ONLY AND
NAME AND ORGANIZATION POSITION
FOR THE RECORD SO.
MISTER MCCARTY PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU GOOD TO BE BACK HAPPY
NEW YEAR AFTER YEAR COMMITTEE.
HOT FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
OVER THE BREAK TO GET THIS BILL
IN ORDER TO BE HEARD TODAY AND.
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS PRESENTED
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT THIS THIS
BILL ESSENTIALLY HELPS TO
IMPROVE.
SCREENINGS FOR CHILDREN BETWEEN
THE AGES OF ZERO THREE THREE.
HELPING THEM GET ARE ON TRACK
TO HAVE PROPER DEVELOPMENTS IN
LIFE AND IN SCHOOL. HOW WE KNOW
THAT?
EARLY BRAIN DEVELOPMENT IS SO
CRITICAL IN THE EARLY FIRST
THREE YEARS OF LIFE.
CAUSING THE BRAIN ARCHITECTURE
TO DEVELOP IT CONVERSELY WHEN
CHALLENGES.
COME AROUND IT IT IT GOES THE
OTHER DIRECTION BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT EARLY IN INTERVENTION IS
KEY. AND.
SCREENINGS CAN IDENTIFY THESE
ISSUES EARLY ON AND FOCUSING ON.
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE CHILD'S IT
IMPACT IN HEALTH AND SCHOOL IN
IN THE LATER YEARS.
WE KNOW THAT.
ADVERSE HOW THE CHILD IMPACTS
CREATES TOXIC STRESS WHICH HAS
HORRIBLE LONG TERM IMPACTS ON
THE THE YOUNG CHILD IN LIFE.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT REMEDIES CAN'T
COME ABOUT BY REGAINING HEAR
FROM OUR WITNESSES TODAY. AND
THAT THISWOULD ALLOW SCREENINGS
AT THE EARLIER LEVELS OF A
CHILD'S EXISTENCE AND BRING
ABOUT BETTER OUTCOMES FOR KIDS.
WITH THAT I HAVE DOCTOR MONEY
PATEL FROM THE UCLA EXCUSE ME U.
S. C..
BIG. BIG PROBLEM. CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AND A BIG MISTAKE
BESSER OF PEDIATRICS
DOCTOR PATEL.
GOOD HAVE AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO COME
AND ADDRESS YOU TODAY I AM
DOCTOR MANTAPA TOWN I COME TO
YOU AS A PEDIATRICIAN WHO CARES
FOR. IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES OF
LOS ANGELES FOR THE PAST
FOURTEEN YEARS.
I MEAN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
CLINICAL PEDIATRICS WITH THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES.
AND THE CO CHAIR OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COUNCIL FOR THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS.
EIGHT CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF
OUR PATIENT CENTERED MEDICAL
HOME FOR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND I WOULD SAY
MOST IMPORTANT I AM THE MOTHER
OF TWO CHILDREN WHO. I'VE
WATCHED GROW AND DEVELOP.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE EPIDEMIC
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY STARTING
WHEN I BEGAN PRACTICING IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
I NOTED INCREASED INCIDENCE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY
PREDOMINANTLY SPEECH DELAY IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
COULDN'T AND I NOTICED THAT MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT I WORKED
ALONGSIDE WE'RE NOT DOING THE
EVIDENCE BASED SCREENING THAT WE
HAVE ALL TIED BEEN TIED TO
DELAYS PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS.
SPECIFICALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE I REMEMBER WALKING INTO A
ROOM AND THE CHART ON THE DOOR
SAID NINE MONTH WELL CHILD
VISIT.
WHEN I WALKED IN THE ROOM I SAW
MOM HOLDING UP HER CHILD
PROPPING HER UP IN A CITY
POSITION AND HOLDING HER HEAD.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE HAD
NINE MONTH WITH CHILDREN WE KNOW
THAT AT THIS AGE THEY SHOULD BE
SITTING THEY SHOULD BE STARTING
TO FEED THEMSELVES. THEY SHOULD
START CRAWLING PULLING
THEMSELVES UP TO STAND IN THIS
TOWN UNFORTUNATELY WAS NOT ABLE
TO DO SO.
I SAT NEXT TO MOM AND I ASK YOU
A BROADER IN THAT DAY AND SHE
SAID SHE IS FRUSTRATED BECAUSE
SHE VISITED MANY DOCTORS AND
THEY ALL THE DOCTORS TOLD HER
CHILDLESS FINE.
AND SHE SAID AS A MOTHER SHE
KNEW THAT HER CHILD WAS NOT
DEVELOPING THE SAME AS HER OTHER
CHILDREN.
pAND SHE WANTED HELP.
I FINISH MY ASSESSMENT AND I DID
A VALIDATED SCREENING TOOL
CALLED THE AGES AND STAGES AND I
CONFIRM THAT HER CHILD DID IN
FACT HAVE GLOBAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAY IN A WORKED WITH AND HER
WITH HER FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
MONTHS. INTEGRATING HER INTO
COMEY BT COMMUNITY BASED
RESOURCE SAYS FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION WHICH ALREADY EXIST
IN THE COMMUNITY.
I'M I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO ON OCTOBER
RIGHT AT HER FIVE YEAR OLD WELL
CHILD VISIT. IN MY P. SHIP RAN
INTO THE ROOM SHE TOLD ME THE
COLOR OF HER PARENTS HE TOLD ME
ALL ABOUT HER KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER AT ROWING ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DOWN THE STREET. SHE'S
MAINSTREAMED AND GRADUATED FROM
THERAPIES AND THIS IS WHY WE'RE
HERE TAKE THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE WE HAVE WHICH
WE WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY THIS
CHILD GETTER INTO EARLY
INTERVENTION RESOURCES AND WE
HAVE CHANGED HER LIFE NOW SHE'S
MAINSTREAM AND THERE'S IN THE
SHE DOES NOT HAVE A NEED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION RESOURCES.
THE PREVALENCE OF JOAN OF THE
LEóN CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO FIVE
HAS INCREASED BY SEVENTEEN POINT
ONE PERCENT IN THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS. WITH UP TO FIFTEEN
PERCENT TWELVE MILE DELAY IN
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES THE
SAME COMMITTEES THAT I SERVE.
THEIR REASONS IS JUSTICE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY MENTIONED
INFLUENCES OF TOXIC STRESS IN
THIS ENVIRONMENT.
MICHAEL CYCLE SOCIAL SOUGHT
STIMULATION FOR CHILDREN. IN
REALLY OVERWHELMINGLY FEWER
RESOURCES THAT EXIST IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
WE NOT THAT WHAT THE LATINO
POPULATION THERE'S AN EVEN
GREATER. CHANCE OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAY UP TO THREE TIMES OTHER
CHILDREN.
IN OUR STATE UNFORTUNATELY
DESPITE THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
PEDIATRICS MANDATING THROUGH
RIGHT FEATURES THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVIDENCE BASE SCREENINGS
WITH VALIDATED MEASURES THAT
NINE MONTHS EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TWENTY FOUR TO THIRTY MONTHS.
AND WITH DHS MANDATING WITH CA
SHEEPY GUIDELINES WE SHOULD BE
DOING THESE. I PERSONALLY LESSEN
A THIRD OF CHILDREN ARE ACTUALLY
SCREENED AND OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW OUR STATE
RANKS FORTY THIRD IN THE NATION
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING AND
WE CAN DO BETTER.
THAT.
THE REASON WHY THIS EARLY
IDENTIFICATION IS SO IMPORTANT
IS AS WAS MENTIONED BETWEEN THE
AGES OF ZERO THREE. THAT'S THE
PRIME TIME THAT THE CHILD'S
BRAIN IS THE MOST PLASTIC WE
CALL IT KNOW PLASTICITY WHICH
MEANS THAT YOU CAN ENGAGE YOU
CAN STIMULATE. YOU CAN GROW YOU
CAN IMPACT A CHILD'S DEVELOPMENT
AND BY THAT YOU CAN IMPACT AND
OPTIMIZE THEIR FUTURE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN I WAS
HONORED TO GET AT LARGE SCALE
GRANT TO STANDARDIZE
OPERATIONALIZE DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENING IN MY CLINIC SYSTEMS
AND I'M PROUD TO SAY AFTER THREE
YEARS. WE'VE GONE FROM A
SCREENING RATE OF TWENTY SIX
PERCENT TO NINETY SIX PERCENT.
WE HAVE SCREENED EIGHT THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN EAST LOS ANGELES WE
KNOW THAT IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS A
SCREEN THAT DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY
RISKS IS BY TWELVE POINT NINE
PERCENT. OF SEVERE TEN TWENTY
PERCENT DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE CONNECTED
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
CHILDREN INTO EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES.
SO THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE
HERE I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER
THESE RESOURCES ALREADY EXIST WE
ARE YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE DOING
THIS AND WE SHOULD BE ALLOCATING
FUNDING AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TOGETHER TO OPTIMIZE. THE FUTURE
FOR THESE CHILDREN STILL THINK
YOU.
I AM HAVING A LITTLE
DONNA AND I AM REPRESENTING
FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION NEWS ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS UP THIS BILL
AND I AM JUST APPEAR ONE FOR
MORAL SUPPORT AND TO.
JUST ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF
THEY DO END UP GETTING DIRECTED
TOWARDS ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER SINCE
SUPPORT.
BUT I HAVE A MINUTE.
TWO EIGHT IN TWO AND A HALF
PUTTING MEN AND THAT'S RIGHT
BACK THERE.
OKAY.
CAN LUIS I REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW IN THE CO SPONSORS OF SPELL
ONE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THE BILL AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE EFFORT WORKING WITH US
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE.
MONEY GRIMACE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
OF LA IN SPORT THINK YOU.
MERE VALDEZ OF HEALTH BOX
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT IF YOU.
KATIE LADEN WITH THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION
REPRESENTING NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PEDIATRIC SPECIALTY
PHYSICIANS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND SUPPORT.
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF
THE CENTER FOR AUTISM RELATED
DISORDERS IN SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARK IN UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION WHERE SUPPORT AND
CONCEPT INTO OUR POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE TENTH TO MEET
TAKE A FORMAL POSITION BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD ON. TO MOVING ON
FOREIGN CONVERSATION WITH BILL.
THEY DO YOU BORN REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
PRETTY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
DETERMINE.
CLAIMS THE CHAIR THEY DO WE
OFTEN TO THE WITNESSES JUST ONE
QUESTION.
.
ABOUT WHAT A BARRIER SO MAKING
THE SCREENING HAPPEN.
WE HAVE A NUMBER PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION TO THIS LIKE EARLY STAR
PROGRAM.
WITHIN.
THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES TO DO THIS TYPE OF
SCREENING. WHAT BARRIERS EXIST
AND WHAT WE NEED TO BE DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT ONCE THIS
LEGISLATION PASSES?
THAT THOSE WHO NEED TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS READINGS IN FACT.
DO GET.
FIVE POINT WE ACTUALLY PUBLISHED
AN ARTICLE LAST YEAR LOOKING AT
THE SAME THING AS WHAT AT THE
VARIATION CHALLENGES TO DEVELOP
ALL SCREENING. AND THE REASONS
AT LEAST FROM THE PROVIDER AND
IS TIME CONSTRAINTS
I'M WE WORK IN BUSY A LOT OF US
IN COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTERS
FQHCS WE HAVE TWENTY MINUTE
APPOINTMENTS. AND IN THOSE
TWENTY MIN APPOINTMENTS WE HAVE
TO DEAL OVERWHELMING
ANTICIPATORY GUIDANCE AND WELL
CHILD CARE.
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SCREENING
TOOLS REMEMBER CHILDREN ARE NOT
SEEN BY ONLY PEDIATRICIANS BUT
MID LEVEL PROVIDERS FAMILY
PRACTICE EVEN ADULT PROVIDERS
AND A LOT OF TIMES. IT DEPENDING
ON YOUR RESIDENTS IN MEDICAL
SCHOOL EDUCATION YOU MAY NOT
HAVE YOU CAN LEARN ABOUT THE
VALIDATED SCREENING TOOLS. AND
THERE IS A MISCONCEPTION IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT DIVERT MENTAL
SURVEILLANCE EQUALS
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING
SURVEILLANCE IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
A CHILD TWO MONTHS THEY SHOULD
BE SMILE THEY SHOULD BE GOING.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME AS ACTUALLY
DOING A FORMALIZED DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREEN.
AND AND MOST PROVIDERS ACTUALLY
UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS THAT DIFFERENCE.
THERE'S ALSO RELIANCE ON
FAMILIES TO REPORT PROBLEMS AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY IN ARE
PREDOMINATELY TINO POPULATION WE
FOUND THAT. A LOT OF THE
FAMILIES DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS NORMAL DEVELOPMENT AND THAT
RECOGNITION ISN'T THERE AND
THERE MAY BE A PROVIDER RELIANCE
ON FAMILIES JUST TELL. THEM WHAT
IS HAPPENING AND THEN FINALLY.
WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW HOW TO EVEN
SCREEN THERE'S ALSO WHAT DO YOU
DO IF YOU HAVE A POSITIVE LIGHT
OF THE PROVIDERS DON'T KNOW THE
SYSTEMS OF CARE AND THE
CHALLENGES AND UNDERSTAND. THIS
REGIONAL CENTER THERE'S
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAN HELP SO IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX MULTI FACTOR.
SURE YOU IN THE AUTHOR GONNA
HELP US TO GET THROUGH THOSE
BARRIERS SO THANK YOU THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
WENDY.
YEAH.
IT HAS MOVED IN WITH BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED SEASON MISS KOREA
SORRY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
AS THE TELL. I GREW UP IN
LEBANESE LOS ANGELES IN THIS THE
COMMUNITY THAT I REPRESENT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE WORK
THEY ARE DOING TO HELP. IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN AND IF
IT'S OKAY WITH YOU MISTER QUICK
I'D LIKE TO MISS MCCARTHY I'M
SORRY WOULD LOVE TO BE OUT OF
THE CLOTH INTO THE.
ANYONE ELSE.
WAS WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
JUMP IN.
.
IT'S KIND OF SHOCKING THAT WERE
FORTY THIRD.
IN THE NATION ON DOING THIS THIS
TYPE OF.
PROGRAM BECAUSE YOU KNOW AS A
MOM.
IT'S I CAN SEE THE DEVELOPMENT
AND IT I THINK WE UNDERESTIMATE
THE ABILITY. OF INFANTS YOU KNOW
HOW MUCH THEY CAN LEARN HOW MUCH
THEY CAN THEN TAKE IN.
YOU KNOW THE AMAZING ASPECT OF
THE BRAIN ITSELF IN ITS
DEVELOPMENT AND.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE NEED AN
OMBUDSMAN TYPE OF THING WITHIN
THIS TO HELP NAVIGATE BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW HOW DO PERRANCE GET
EDUCATED THAT MAYBE THIS
ASSIGNMENT SOMETHING'S NOT
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A WHOLE MULTI
FACTUAL THING SO.
LINE SUPPORT THE BUT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO IN. IMMIGRATE TO
SEE US IMPROVE HANNAH THE FORTY
THIRD POSITION.
ANYONE ELSE MR MRS R..
THANK YOU I ORDINARILY WOULDN'T
OF SPOKEN AT THIS POINT I WOULD
HAVE JUST SAID ME TOO I LOVE THE
SITE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. BUT SINCE I HAVE A
CONSTITUENT ARE ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THIS. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU CONTINUALLY DO.
THANK YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL
SERVICE THAT YOU PROVIDE. TO
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AS WELL. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTHY THANKS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'D
LOVE TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHORS
WELL.
CAN ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NO ONE.
IT WE HAD A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTION WAS BY.
IS THAT YOU'RE CARRYING THE
SECOND BY THE SLOW MOAN SO WHAT
THAT MEANT EXACTLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I PUT
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MANSTEIN AYE
TACKY R. CURRY I. THINK ARE
CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE KOREA AYE RIO AYE.
BURKE. BIRTH AYE FLORA.
FLORA EILEMA. BEMOAN AYE MCCARTY
AYE MCCARTY AYE.
THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SPOT SANTIAGO. I'D
SANTIAGO AYE STEINORTH.
THURMOND. THURMAN AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S IS FOURTEEN ZERO AND WITH
MR STEINORTH BEEN ABSENT THAT
WILL. ARE MEETING ACTUALLY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WITH MCCARTY THINK FOR THE
BILL THINKING APPRECIATE THANK
YOU.
MEETING ADJOURNED.